[Musique]
le royaume-uni rouvre
deux restaurants après quatre mois de
fermeture outre-manche 60% de la
population adulte a reçu au moins une
dose de vaccin une première gorgée de
bière à la saveur particulière
elle est vraiment bonne ça a le goût de
la liberté sur ses vidéos postées sur
les réseaux sociaux
plusieurs dizaines de personnes
patientent sur un parking
elles attendent leur tour avant de
rentrer dans une soirée clandestine à
l'intérieur alcool musique et même
jacuzzi le tout sans masque et sans
respect des gestes-barrières alertés par
les voisins dans la nuit les gendarmes
arrivent sur les lieux et verbalisent
près d'une centaine de participants
mes amis qui ont à la chopé le virus
j'en ai un pack 1 évidemment à leurs
enfants
mais évidemment voilà et moi je vois
attendait mes enfants est encore une
fois j'ai trois finir à 10 ans donc il
ya beaucoup de garçons autour mais le
couvre-feu ils n'en ont rien à cirer je
peux vous dire les personnes qui ont
participé à ces fêtes si elles sont
responsables je les appelle à aller se
faire tester et ensuite à s'isoler
pendant sept à dix jours afin de ne pas
propager le virus davantage
brice hortefeux ancien ministre et puis
alain duhamel journaliste up chauffé à
déjeuner non moi je suis un chronicles
et la chronique des événements sur le
sur le sujet dans sa masse pire de
chaussée m'inspire que dans ce moment
particulier évidemment l'exemplarité des
politiques de ceux qui ont des
responsabilités publiques au médiatique
et est importante
déjeuner dans un restaurant clandestins
vous paraît très légal sûr que non je
vous dis ça parce que c'est ce que
explique brice hortefeux ça vous paraît
très légal non non bon la règle doit
être la même pour tout le monde
la veille j'ai reçu un sms pour me
donnant une adresse différente
comme c'est une adresse privée sans
aucune autre précision
j'ai cru que c'était peut-être soit son
appartement soit un bureau qui l'avait
ailleurs et quand je suis arrivé je suis
rentré je me suis aperçu que ça n'était
pas du tout ce que j'avais pu imaginer
pensé et encore moins voulu vous pensez
qu'ils sont de bonne foi
écoutez c'est un journaliste qui qui
invite un homme politique dans un
appartement gers en l'occurrence bon
voici ou alors c'est un homme politique
invite à journal dans un appartement moi
je ne sais pas ce qui s'est passé je ne
sais rien de cette histoire
immédiatement il a dit il a dit que oui
c'était lui qui avait organisé que oui
moi j'étais comme moi je ne savais rien
et il m'a présenté ses regrets donc
voilà il a été correct à 10 ans qu'il a
été mal inspiré sentons droit de café le
virus brésilien au brésil si jamais ils
montrent ici il est en petite quantité
attention hein si jamais il explose en
france
est on en train de le voir apparaître
dans d'autres régions du monde au canada
ils sont inquiets si jamais il expose
ici alors on va remettre en cause toute
la politique vaccinale la raim voit bien
que sondage après sondage que elle va
vers une déroute à ces élections locales
et comme elle ne veut pas avoir des deux
défaites électorales à moins d'un an de
la présidentielle
elle cherche des prétextes pour les
reporter c'est inconstitutionnel
tout le monde a bien compris la manip la
manip la majorité a peur de se prendre
une taule monumentale aux élections
régionales dont qui s'essaye de
repousser les choses
à titre personnel je souhaite que les
élections deux fils se maintenir au
moins de gens parce que je pense que la
démocratie est fondamental et que chacun
a le droit de s'exprimer
nous avons déjà repoussé d'ailleurs avec
le parlement ces élections et que
personne ne se livre à de misérables
petits calculs politiques si jamais sa
tante est certain vous pensez que sa
tante certains sa tante qui le président
de la république le premier ministre
pose est bien là qu'est sur la majorité
présidentielle j'ajoute que c'est
compliqué pour le gouvernement de dire
je rouvre les terrasses des restaurants
le 15 mai et je ferme les bureaux de
vote le 15 juin la différence et ça
s'appelle confiner la démocratie un
prêtre breton et une religieuse
originaire de mayenne kidnappé en haïti
en tout au moins dix personnes enlevées
les ravisseurs demandent une rançon d'un
mille
en dollars